the continuous function G is graphed
we're interested in the area under the
curve between x equals negative 7 and x
equals 7 and we're considering using
Riemann sums to approximate it so this
is the area that we're thinking about in
this light blue color order the areas
from least on top to greatest on bottom
so this is a screenshot from Khan
Academy exercise where you would be
expected to actually click and drag
these around but it's just a screenshot
so what I'm gonna do instead of dragging
them around I'm just gonna write numbers
ordering them from least to greatest
where one would be the least and then 3
would be the greatest so pause this
video and try to think about these which
of these is the least which is in the
middle and which is the greatest so
let's just draw out what a left Riemann
sum a right Riemann sum would actually
look like and compare it to the actual
area and we could do an arbitrary number
of subdivisions I would encourage us to
do a few because you were because we're
just trying to get a general sense of
things and they don't even have to be
equal subdivisions so let's start with a
left Riemann sum so we want to start at
x equals negative 7 and we want to go to
x equals 7 well let's say that this is
the first rectangle right over here so
this is our first subdivision and it's
the left Riemann sum so we would use the
value of the function at the left end of
that subdivision which is negative 7 x
equals negative 7 the value of the
function there is 12 and so this would
be our first rectangle you already get a
sense that this is going to be an
overestimate relative to the actual area
and so the next subdivision would start
here so this would be our height of our
rectangle and let's say they don't have
to be equal subdivisions they often are
but I'm going to show you unequal
subdivisions just to show you that this
is still a valid Riemann sum and once
again this is an over estimate where the
actual area that we're trying to
approximate is smaller than the area of
this rectangle and then let's say this
third subdivision right over here starts
right over there at x equals 3 and we
use the left end of the subdivision the
value of the function there to define
the height of the rectangle and once
again you see it is an over estimate so
the left Riemann sum is clearly an over
an over estimate
and it's pretty clear why this function
is this function never increases it's
either decreasing or it looks like it
stays flat at certain points and so for
a function like that the left edge the
value of the function at the left edge
is going to be just as high or higher
than any other value of than any other
value the function takes on over that
interval for the subdivision and so you
get left with all of this extra area
that is part of the over estimate or
this area that is larger than the actual
area of that you're trying to
approximate now think about a right
Riemann sum and I'll do different
subdivisions let's say the first
subdivision goes from negative 7 to
negative 5 and here we would use the
right edge to define the height so f of
negative 5 or G of negative 5 I should
say so that's right over there
that's our first rectangle maybe our
next rectangle the right edge is zero so
this would be it right over there and
then maybe maybe you'll do four
rectangles maybe our third subdivision
the right edge is that X is equal to
three so it would be right over there
and then our fourth subdivision let's
just do it at x equals seven and we're
using the right edge of the subdivisions
remember this is a right Riemann sum so
we use the right edge the value of the
function there is just like that and now
you can see for any one of these
subdivisions our rectangles are under
estimates of the area under the curve
under under estimate and that's because
once again in this particular case the
function never increases it's either
decreasing or staying flat so if you use
the value of the function at the right
edge it's going to be smaller it's going
to be it's never going to be larger than
the value that the function takes on in
the rest of that subdivision and so we
are continuously under estimating we're
missing this all of all of this area
right over there is not being included
so we have an under estimate so if we
want to rank these from least to
greatest well the right Riemann sum
is the least it is under estimating it
then you have the actual area of the
curve which is just the area of the
curve and then you have the left Riemann
sum which is the over estimate